supongamos que tenemos un globo y dentro
de este globo tenemos un montón de
partículas moviéndose partículas
gaseosas que flotan libremente y todas
ellas tienen una velocidad una energía
cinética y lo que a mí me interesa
voy a dibujar un poquito más lo que me
interesa es la presión que se está
ejerciendo sobre la superficie del globo
así que me interesa la presión y que es
presión es fuerza entre área fuerza
entre ay el área aquí podemos verla como
la superficie interior del globo y qué
es lo que aplica la fuerza a eso bueno
aquí solo he dibujado seis partículas
pero en un globo real tendríamos
millones de partículas y aunque
podríamos hablar de qué tamaño son de
cualquier manera tenemos muchísimas más
de las que podemos imaginar y en algún
momento muchas de esas partículas chocan
con las paredes del contenedor esta
choca aquí está choca acá y cuando
chocan aplican una fuerza al contenedor
que provoca que el globo esté inflado
entonces vamos a pensar la presión de
que depende primero entre más rápido se
muevan estas partículas mayor presión
existe
partículas rápidas
partículas rápidas implican que la
presión aumenta partículas lentas
significa que estarán chocando menos
entre ellas o con las paredes y cuando
esto pasa se empujan menos entonces
partículas lentas implican que la
presión disminuye ahora es prácticamente
imposible medir la energía cinética o la
velocidad por la dirección de cada una
de las partículas especialmente porque
hay millones de ellas entonces lo que
hacemos es calcular la energía promedio
de las partículas y la energía promedio
es ya han de pensar ya nos va a
introducir a un nuevo concepto lo que es
cierto pero de una manera familia para
ustedes qué es la temperatura
temperatura es y la deberíamos ver cómo
la energía promedio de las partículas en
el sistema se parece a energía promedio
o mayormente energía cinética verdad
porque estas partículas se están
y chocando a mayor temperatura más
rápido se van a mover estas partículas y
más van a chocar con las paredes del
contenedor pero temperatura es energía
promedio lo que significa energía
energía por partícula o entre partículas
si queremos saber el total ya sabe
obviamente que si sólo tuviéramos una
partícula y una temperatura muy alta
habría menor presión de la que hay con
millones de partículas colisionando
déjenme dibujar si tuviera vamos a poner
dos casos en el primero tengo un montón
de partículas a una cierta temperatura
moviéndose en diferentes direcciones
y en el otro caso tengo una partícula
tal vez en los dos casos tengo la misma
temperatura es decir la misma energía la
energía cinética por partícula es la
misma claramente habrá más presión
ejercida sobre la superficie porque en
cualquier momento
muchas de estas partículas chocan contra
las paredes pero en este caso la
partícula chocará menos veces lo que
aplicará menor presión aún cuando la
temperatura sea la misma por partícula
como ya habíamos dicho energía cinética
por partícula
si queremos saber la energía total del
sistema tendremos que multiplicar la
temperatura por el número de partículas
presentes es decir hay que recordar lo
que sabemos sobre el número de
partículas recuerden que el mol es una
forma de representar el número de
partículas entonces decimos que la
presión es igual a una constante vamos a
llamarla
no importa que constante en este caso
vamos a llamarla erp
las unidades las vemos al final no se
preocupen por ello ahorita entonces
decimos que es igual a una constante por
la temperatura por el número de
partículas si tenemos por ejemplo sin
como les al multiplicarlos por 6 por 10
a la 23 es decir el número de avogadro
tenemos el número de partículas entonces
esto es número de partículas temperatura
y una constante constante ahí está de
qué otra cosa depende de la presión
vimos estos dos ejemplos que dependiendo
de la temperatura más rápido se moverán
y mayor presión tendrán también depende
del número de partículas a mayor
partículas mayor presión y qué pasa con
el tamaño del contenedor
el volumen tomemos este ejemplo pero
vamos a encoger lo por la presión que
existe en el exterior
se vería algo así y aún tiene la misma
cantidad de partículas en el interior
las mismas partículas la misma energía
cinética o la misma temperatura entonces
las partículas son las mismas
la temperatura es igual pero el volumen
ha disminuido en cualquier momento estas
partículas van a chocar muchísimo más
con las paredes y tenemos menos área
verdad entonces en algún momento
tendremos más fuerza y menor área
la presión subirá cuando el volumen
disminuye la presión aumenta
la presión es inversamente proporcional
al volumen
vamos a escribirlo en la ecuación
dijimos que presión
perdón presión habíamos dicho que es
igual a una constante por la temperatura
por vamos a escribirlo constante por el
número de partículas por la temperatura
y todo eso es inversamente proporcional
al volumen proporcional es decir entre
el volumen entonces si multiplicamos
ambos lados de la igualdad por el
volumen obtenemos que la presión por el
volumen es igual a r por el número de
partículas por la temperatura bv es
igual a rn t
si quieren acomodar esto para que lo
vean como lo encuentran en los libros de
química sólo cambiamos el horno tenemos
presión por volumen es igual al número
de partículas por una constante por la
temperatura
esta es la ecuación del gas ideal espero
que ya tenga sentido para ustedes
es ideal mejor dicho
ecuación del gas ideal atención al decir
casi ideal nos basamos en estos ejemplos
donde hice algunas suposiciones
implícitas una que asumí es que estamos
trabajando con un gas ideal y que es un
gas ideal un gas ideal es aquel donde
las moléculas no tienen mucha relación
entre ellas sino más bien con su energía
cinética y las interacciones que tengan
con las paredes significa que no se
atraen ni se repelen entre ellas no se
atraen o repelen entre ellas si se
atrajeron entre ellas y si tuviéramos
muchas quizá no querrían estar cerca de
las paredes sino que se sentirían
atraídas hacia el centro para estar más
juntas si hubiera atracción entre ellas
y si esto pasara entonces chocarían
menos con las paredes y la presión sería
menor
entonces asumimos que no se atraen ni se
repelen entre sí y también hay que
asumir que el volumen actual de cada
partícula individual es despreciable
esto es una buena suposición ya que son
muy pequeñas sólo si pusiéramos una
tonelada de partículas en un cierto
volumen sobre todo partículas grandes
ahí si nos preocuparíamos por su tamaño
pero estamos asumiendo que para
propósitos de nuestro ejercicio mental
podemos despreciar
volumen de las moléculas y que no se
atraen o repelen entre ellas en esa
situación podemos aplicar la ley del gas
ideal esta de aquí ahora establecimos la
ecuación del gas ideal pero se han de
preguntar oye pero qué hago con ella
como la puede usar para resolver
problemas en qué unidades se trabaja
bueno todo eso lo veremos en el
siguiente vídeo
haremos muchísimos ejercicios pero
ahorita lo más importante es tener una
idea del tema y sobre todo entender de
dónde y por qué salió esta ecuación así
podemos hacer las cosas por nosotros
mismos